John what times of change Greg have they
changed
yeah well I don't know but there's a new
Blade Runner and there's a time to live
featurette released by Warner Brothers
oh boy
I love Warner Brothers sometimes yeah
yeah they're very sometimes company now
all of them are except for maybe like a
24 and blum house and for house yeah no
yeah definitely it's one of the three
there's no one is not going over dad hey
guys Vegas one one ball head you got
once
I was good at it I know what do you mean
don't ask you some questions
or buy a story the fiends
this is done in visual environment
dialog er simple word pleasure getting
back to the world of Blade Runner again
definitely
[Music]
pleasure offense a disco I could never
the master iconic instilled a dominant
had respect for the world the briefly
star critic his runner revolutionized
the way we do science fiction
when I heard that relieve is continuing
the narrative
I was already invested I already wanted
to know what happened next I think it
kind of fun to play a character 30 years
later we used to try on old clothes how
happily they still fit and massage Rafi
to the script to walking with Denis and
Ridley Roger Harrison please I just feel
really lucky just to be on the team
I've never felt that much pressure of my
shoulder thinking that we discovered
this movie I've never worked in a film
with so many set consists of lighting
patterns that literally taught
showmanship
that created this incredible world with
it was a living breathing universe
defining this was like walking on a
knife's edge lighting the line between
the original film and what we're doing
now like it's not just a record with the
custom we've married the chameleons with
slightly delayed management in order to
give ourselves an identifier ah so what
divergently keep the visual sex very
reality base and grounded people getting
their water it's a beautiful shot out of
together
[Music]
I told you
story
is always meant to stumble and settle
that is all smokes count with two hours
of loud yeah making specially for this
counter in crowded realistic extension
of the original it's good the elegant
puja breaks lon
you're here
[Music]
[Music]
now be so surprised this movie is not
good yeah I mean this really looks so
cool it's one of those rare sequels that
I can you just see the the imagery know
who's behind it was in front of the
camera and seeing that really Scott was
on set for a lot of it because I didn't
know if he was one of those people who
put his name on it yeah or if he was
actually involved like yeah I'll show up
on set I'll be involved in the creative
process knowing he's involved in the
creative process but not actually
direction yeah a little pretty sure in
some ways - yeah I like Prometheus and
government well it's clear after
watching those movies that this is the
place he really wants to be yeah so I
mean even even his involvement makes me
feel a little bit better about this
movie yeah this movie seems like it's
much more in line with the ideas he's
interested in so I imagine his being
back to probably be pretty good looking
to the art director talking about
blending the style with honoring the
original and then also a hybrid of their
own take as well okay like what Graham
you said that that's like yes what
exactly what I don't want is a 30 years
updated version of the the work is the
most disappointing things and you can't
like filmmakers say what they wanna do
or intended and you like see trailers or
see the movie itself like The Mummy and
you're like this ain't nothing like what
they said I wanted to do it actually the
object of what you said you want to do
everything they're saying they want to
do it looks like they're going to honor
it and I think like nine times out of
ten were right when we watch an
Elizabeth and in such comments as we get
it like you can't really judge it until
you see the movie yes that is
technically very much true however with
that being said I feel like a lot of the
time our predictions if we think of
movies actually going to live up to it
for be good or whatever we tend to be
right we've done this enough times now
to Italy we can make a decent for dinner
and I feel like this movie will be good
I love how we're still not getting
details on the story we don't need
details on the story okay I'm warranty
two submission that Gosling is going on
and then he needs their supports help at
some point in the movie jail it looks
like the bad guy now okay what it's just
knowing that all the important details
to the plot I don't need to know any
more now Greg I need three more trailers
maybe I find more clips I want a full
spiderman job and I want to see it
before I even see it even more so than
just with the trailers like seeing
everybody they have it involved with
this is what gives me the most
confidence like the combination of the
images that look amazing and just you
know you've got Harrison Ford Ryan
Gosling and Denis Villeneuve and and
Rajan's makes weeks speaking like it's a
tremendous team they've assemble and
that would be very surprised if this
didn't work deacons and Denis have
worked together before as well it seems
like a camaraderie style of a team
assembled together that knows exactly
what they want to do what they want to
live up to because Blade Runner is one
of the most influential sci-fi films in
cinematic history yeah this feels like a
like and I get a very authentic vibe off
yeah it doesn't feel like well let's
make it a sequel and it's like
everyone's really invested and it seems
like there's stuff you could do thirty
years later with a story like Blade
Runner especially with the advances in
not only just technology but also art
you should tell us who we keep hearing
about and stuff because you know it's
oftentimes when you do these revisiting
a world decades later in cinema or worse
if you do a pretty cool in the
technology's way better yeah maybe is
Star Wars The Hobbit yeah guys
everything so much better like it would
have more abilities than they will in
the future if this even takes place
later on in the timeline of Blade Runner
so you could get even crazier with a
special-effects well they didn't go
overboard with it it's something it's
like this looks like Blade Runner yeah
this is like it like a while into the
future yeah and that's I mean that's
part of the charm of the
the original 1/2 is the perfect blend of
like a heady story but with all that
film noir style and and yeah a future
that looks really alien in comparison to
our own world but still looks plausible
time you know I'm wondering what
messages or metaphors their themes
they're looking to explore that here
because I think Blade Runner was a good
one off as he was saying like it was
meant to be a standalone film and this
is that film that I think you can
continue as well because it's just three
cuts of Blade Runner for a reason yeah
they're really solely on engines it is
obvious that really guys nothing bad
will be right I promise you guys and
also I mean didn't you feel new if you
wasn't making this he would be making a
blade runner's yeah I'm soon I feel
likely he's the choice he said in our
last trailer review that what we saw the
Blade Runner movie the day before we saw
that trailer we were like yeah it looks
like Danny Villa new agenda leader area
looks like it exactly made for your
style my friend house go nuts we did get
a shot of who's the actor plays Morgan
from The Walking Dead you guys name oh
no but I love that guy at least though
there's at least in the few places I've
seen him it really gets tremendous a
damn good actor and they should like a
brief image of him here I didn't even
know he's involved in development no but
I hope he gets some good screen time as
well because when you tease an actor
like that I hate when you tease like a
TV actor and movie and they like don't
do anything yeah yeah there's one scene
and it's not very important yeah yeah I
definitely hope he's got a chance to
shine because he's always it especially
The Walking Dead he's always a treat
every so often they'll give you one
episode this is all about him and those
are usually some of my favorites now
I'll just have Harrison Ford he keeps
returning to his older characters but I
think he does it in a better fashion
than this Arnold and Stallone does it I
mean actually rocky films have been
pretty damn good oh it's oh look at her
there's something about Harrison Ford to
me now that's funny because it's like in
the first the first time they cut to him
sort of talking to the camera and a
little interview portion oddly he looks
just like a grumpy bowl of oatmeal like
he always says to me just like kind of
mm-hmm but uh there's something about
the more times I've seen him return to
to his older stuff you know it seems
like he really shows up for these things
and like Blade Runner is a movie
I don't think he would phone now we got
a new witness yeah witness to witness
with the witness a witness witnesses
yeah Jean book his back get a younger
actor - yeah yeah and then the new
hotshot Kris pamphlet
you were once a witness we need you back
then more people have been killed at the
train station is the train station
bathroom movie tarnish pronoun you know
as much as this is a sequel film and I
felt done for fans as well I could see
this so my lease on the production value
side I mean think of like fury road I
could see that so in the production side
getting Oscar consideration at least or
Roger Deakins and cinematography or for
the art direction oh yeah this isn't
nominated very release for some kind of
technical or I would be surprised
because just like that that was the off
tax or a loan of the very first trailer
we saw it was just like oh my god let's
come out in October later is not a forum
but there are these unsettling elements
and come to Blade Runner that you can
see being in October release well this
is actually set during Halloween so Ryan
Gosling's trying to find him so they can
go trick-or-treating together because
like he's is fun and like you've never
they're morons like it's about time you
know I can do it Ryan Gosling approaches
these are great predictions you can
totally good predictions well because
it's so vague I don't know well guys
thanks for sending that our way you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
click that notification belt you can
follow John Humphrey John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram and you can check
him out on blog house com1 on there is a
social media manager for it last but not
least check out our exclusive for Perks
works and re-run words at patreon.com
slash the real rejects having a lot of
[ __ ] ton fun / puppet up there yeah and
if you want to hey if you're looking for
some new duds for the so time however to
our Spreadshirt store get yourself a
real rejects tea or a phone case or
something that's new watch Blade Runner